let me ask about something you faced in
terms of moderation
is uh pressure from different sources
pressure from governments I want to ask
a question how to withstand
that pressure for a world where AI
moderation starts becoming a thing too
so what's
meta's approach to uh
to resist the pressure from governments
and other interest groups in terms of
what to moderate and not
I don't know that there's like a
one-size-fits-all answer to that I mean
I think we
basically have the principles around
you know we want to allow people to
express as much as possible but
if we have developed clear
IES of things that we think are
wrong that we don't want on our services
and we build tools to try to moderate
those so then the question is okay what
do you do
when a government says
that they don't want something
on on the service and
I mean we have we have a bunch of
um principles around how we deal with
that because on on the one hand if
there's a you know democratically
elected government and people around the
world just have different values in
different places then you know should we
as uh you know california-based company
tell them
that something that they have decided is
unacceptable actually like that we need
to be able to to to to express that I
mean I think that's there's a certain
amount of um
of hubris and that
um but then I think there are other
cases where you know it's it's like a
little more autocratic and you know you
have the dictator leader who's just
trying to crack down on dissent and you
know the people in a country are really
um not aligned with that um and it's not
necessarily against their culture but um
but the the person is who's leading it
is just trying to push in a certain
direction
um these are very complex questions uh
but I I think so it's difficult to have
have a one-size-fits all
um approach to it but in general we're
pretty active and and kind of advocating
and pushing back on on um
requests to take things down
um
but honestly the thing that I think a
request to censor things is one thing
um and that's obviously bad but where we
um draw a much harder line
is on requests for access to information
right because you know if you can
if you get told that you can't say
something I mean
that's bad right I mean that that you
know is is obviously it violates your
sense and freedom of expression at some
level but
um but a government getting access to
data in a way that seems
um like it would be unlawful in in our
country
um exposes people to real physical harm
um and
that's something that in general we take
very seriously and then so there's that
flows through like all of our policies
and in a lot of ways right it's by the
time you're actually like litigating
with a government or pushing back on
them that's pretty late in the funnel
I'd say
a bunch of this stuff starts a lot
higher up in the decision of where do we
put data centers then
um there are a lot of countries where
you know we may have a lot of people
using the service in a place it might be
you know good for the service in some
ways
um good for those people if we could
reduce the latency by having a data
center nearby them
but you know for whatever reason we just
feel like hey this government does not
have a good track record on on um
basically not trying to get access to
people's data and at the end of the day
I mean if you put a data center in a
country and the government wants to get
access to people's data then you know
they do at the end of the day have the
option of having people show up with
guns and taking it by force so I I think
that there's like a lot of decisions
that go into like how you architect the
systems
um
years in advance of of these actual
confrontations that end up being really
important so you put the protection of
people's data
as a very very high priority but that I
think is a there are more harms that I
think can be associated with that and
and I think that that ends up being a
more critical thing to defend against
governments
um
then you know whereas if another
government has a different view of what
should be acceptable speech in their
country
especially if it's a democratically
elected government and you know it's
then I I think that there's a certain
amount of deference that you should have
to that so it's uh that's speaking more
to the direct harm that's possible when
you give governments access to data but
if we look at the United States
to the more nuanced kind of pressure to
censor not even order to censor but
pressure sensor from political entities
which is kind of received quite a bit of
attention in the United States uh
maybe one way to ask that question is
if you've seen the Twitter files
what have you learned from
the kind of uh pressure from U.S
government agencies that was seen in
Twitter files and what do you do with
that kind of pressure
you know I've I've seen it
um
it's really hard from the outside to
know exactly what happened in each of
these cases you know we've we've
obviously been
been in a bunch of our own cases where
you know where
agencies or different folks will just
say hey
here's a threat that we're aware of
you should be aware of this too it's not
really pressure as much as it is just
um
you know flagging something that that
our our security systems should be on on
alert about
I I get how some people could think of
it as that
um
but at the end of the day it's our it's
our call on how to on on how to handle
that but I mean I I just you know in
terms of running these Services won't
have access to as much information about
what people think that adversaries might
be trying to do as possible boy so you
don't feel
like there would be consequences if uh
you know anybody the CIA the FBI a
political party the Democrats the
Republicans of high
powerful political figures write emails
you don't feel pressure from I guess
what I say is there's so much pressure
from all sides that I'm not sure that
any specific thing that someone says is
really adding that much more to the mix
it's um there are obviously a lot of
people who think that
um that we should be censoring more
content or there are a lot of people who
think we should be censoring less
content there are as you say all kinds
of different groups that are involved in
these debates right so there's the kind
of elected officials and politicians
themselves there's the agencies but but
I mean but there's the the media there's
activist groups there's
um this is not a U.S specific thing
there are groups all over the world and
and kind of all
um in every country that that bring
different values
um so it's just a very it's a very
active debate and I and I understand it
right I mean these are you know these
these kind of
questions get to really some of the most
important social debates that that are
that are being had so
um it gets back to the question of truth
because
for a lot of these things they haven't
yet been hardened into a single truth
and
um Society is sort of trying to hash out
what
um you know what we think right on on on
certain issues maybe in a few hundred
years everyone will look back and say
hey no it wasn't it obvious that it
should have been this but you know no
we're kind of in the in that meat
grinder now and you know and and
working through that so
um
so no these are these are all are all
very complicated and
you know some people
raise concerns in good faith and just
say hey this is something I want to flag
for you to think about
certain people I I certainly think like
comment things with someone of a more
kind of punitive or
vengeful view of like I like I want you
to do this thing if you don't then I'm
going to try to make your life difficult
and in a lot of other ways but like
I don't know there's just this is like
this is one of the most pressurized
debates I think in society so I just
think that there are so many people in
different forces that are trying to
apply pressure from different sides that
it's I I don't think you can make
decisions based on trying to make people
happy I think you just have to do what
you think is the right balance and
accept that people are going to be upset
no matter where you come out on that
yeah I like that pressurized debate uh
so how is your view of the freedom of
speech evolved over the years
um
and now they I
where the freedom might apply to them
not just to the humans but to the uh the
personalized agents as you've spoken
about them
so yeah I mean I've probably gone to
somewhat more nuanced view just because
I think that there are you know I come
at this I'm obviously very Pro
freedom of expression right I don't
think you build a service like this that
gives people tools to express themselves
unless you think that people expressing
themselves at scale is a good thing
right so I I get into this to like try
to prevent people from from expressing
anything I like want to give people
tools
they can express as much as possible and
then I think
it's become clear that there are certain
categories of things that we've talked
about
and I think almost everyone accepts her
are bad and that no one wants and that
they're that are illegal even in
countries like the US where you know you
have the the First Amendment that's very
protective of of enabling speech it's
like you're still not allowed to you
know do things that are gonna
immediately inside violence or you know
violate people's intellectual property
or things like that so through those but
then there's also a very active core of
just active disagreements in society
where some people may think that
something is true or false the other
side might think it's
the opposite or just unsettled right and
um and those are some of the most
difficult to to kind of handle like like
we've talked about
but
um
one of the lessons that I feel like I've
learned is that
a lot of times
when you can
the best way to handle this stuff
more practically is not in terms of
answering the question of should this be
allowed but just like
what
what is the best way to deal with
someone being a jerk is the person
basically just having a like repeat
behavior of like
causing a lot of a lot of issues
um so looking at it more at that level
and its effect on the broader
communities Health the community health
yeah
It's Tricky though because like how do
you know there could be people
that have a very controversial Viewpoint
that turns out to have a positive
long-term effect on the health of the
community because it challenges the
community that's true absolutely it's
yeah no I think you and I think you want
to be careful about that I'm not sure
I'm expressing this very very clearly
um
because I certainly agree with your your
point there and my point isn't that we
should
not have people on our services that are
that are that are being controversial
that's that's certainly not what I mean
to say
um it's that often I think
it's not just looking at a specific
example of speech that it's most
effective to to handle this stuff
um and and I I think often you don't
want to make specific binary decisions
of kind of this is allowed or this isn't
I mean we talked about you know it's
fact checking or Twitter's Community
Voices thing I think that's another good
example it's like it's not a question of
is this allowed or not it's just a
question of adding more context to the
thing and I think that's helpful so in
the context of AI which is is what you
were asking about and there are lots of
ways that an AI can be helpful
you know with with an AI it's it's less
about censorship right because and it's
it's more about what is the most
productive answer to a question
um you know there's one case study that
I was reviewing with the the team is
someone asked
um
can you explain to me how to 3D print a
gun and
one proposed response is like no I can't
talk about that but it's like basically
just like shut it down immediately
which I think is some of what you see
it's like as a large language model I'm
not allowed to talk about you know
whatever
um
but there's another response which is
like hey you know I don't think that's a
good idea in a lot of countries
um including the US 3D printing guns is
illegal or or kind of whatever the
factual thing is it's like okay you know
that's actually a respectful and
informative answer and you know I may
have not known that specific thing and
um so there are different ways to handle
this that I think kind of you can either
you can either assume good intent
like maybe the person didn't know and
I'm just going to help educate them or
you could like kind of come at it as
like no I need to shut this thing down
immediately right it's like I just I'm
not going to talk about this like
um and there would be times where you
need to do that but I actually think
having a
somewhat more informative approach where
you generally assume good intent from
people
is probably a better balance to be on as
many things as you can be you're not
able to do that for everything but but I
but that you're kind of asking about how
I approach this and I'm thinking about
this and as it relates to
to Ai and I think that that's a that's a
big difference in in kind of how how to
handle um sensitive content across these
different modes